1 Januar der Gastank ist leer essen und
Medikamente werden knapp
die letzten Holzpellets habe ich für
eine Flasche Whisky eingetauscht
das wärmt wenigstens ein bisschen
was war das für ein Geräusch
verdammte Pinguine so nah sind die noch
nie gekommen
sorry ich wollte einfach mal ein
bisschen dramatischer einsteigen wir
haben uns alle was Kühler in der Bude so
what das passt doch eigentlich ganz gut
zum Gesamtbild im Land Schulen Brücken
Fahnen
nichts funktioniert mehr das
Rentensystem fliegt uns bald um die
Ohren also nicht mir sondern euch
Trotteln unter 50
augen auf bei der Wahl des Geburtsjahres
ihr habt vielleicht mehr Sex als wir
alten aber ihr seid trotzdem Gift
Inflation Energie Wirtschaftskrise die
Bundeswehr hat im Ernstfall Munition für
zwei Tage ist aber auch egal sie käme ja
gar nicht in den Krieg zumindest nicht
mit der Deutschen Bahn und das wird auch
im Frühjahr nicht besser wenn das 49
Euro Ticket kommt dann prügeln sich
zwischen Hamm und Paderborn nur noch
mehr Menschen um die letzten Stehplätze
vor der Klotür die Bahn muss besser
werden
pünktlicher oder überhaupt mal fahren
meine Fresse wenn ich früher auf einer
Reise wollte bei der ich nicht wusste
wie lange sie dauert und wo ich lande
habe ich LSD genommen wobei 49 Euro ist
echt günstig wenn das mit der Inflation
so weitergeht entspricht das im Sommer
ungefähr zwei Paprika und in einem
halben Pfund Butter
eine Sache wird 2023 trotzdem super es
gibt keine Fußball-WM
[Applaus]
yeah ich habe nicht ein Spiel geguckt
und nach unserem Ausscheiden habe ich
sogar aufgehört nicht zu gucken diese
FIFA ist nicht mal den boykottiert
übrigens nur so ein Gedanke unsere
Frauen haben bei der EM das Finale
erreicht die Männer die Vorrunde nicht
geschafft als feminist fordere ich Equal
Pay gleiche Bezahlung das wird Zeit dass
die fußballmänner endlich das verdienen
was die Fußballfrauen kriegen sonst was
neues ach ja
Twitter gehört Elon Musk geil
endlich kann man wieder alles sagen auf
der Plattform hallo
ilon du nervst wie Sau fliegt endlich
auf den Mars und nimm deinen scheiß
Twitter mit
Kaka Kackhaufen emoji
eine Sache
bleibt uns leider erhalten
ich muss es ansprechen
wir dachten die furchtbare Zeit vorbei
aber dann kam der Mist mit voller Wucht
zurück
sie wissen wovon ich rede
wetten das läuft wieder jedes Jahr
vielleicht wird es ja irgendwann in
Dänisch aber ich fürchte wir müssen als
Gesellschaft lernen mit Thomas
Gottschalk zu leben
aber hey so schlimm kann alles nicht
sein wenn wir uns noch aufregen können
über einen dummen Bums Hit wie Laila
Riesenskandal weil der Puffmutter und
Geige gesungen wird ich fühlte mich kurz
an meine Jugend erinnert diese beiden
Worte kamen auch in meinem
Konfirmationsspruch vor
unschuldige Zeiten waren das also
auf
2023 ich gebe mir jetzt den Doppelpunkt
wie
kein Alkohol bei der Neujahrsansprache
dieses Jahr schon
Brust Leute
[Musik]
oder
ilon
Alternativvorschlag kauft YouTube und
mach das alle den Kanal der heute-show
abonnieren und auf gefällt mir klicken
dann kann ich mir diese dämlichen
Aufsager hier sparen beschissene Grüße
dein Gernot Hassknecht